estamos en el cañón del guape en el
centro de Colombia un lugar que hasta
2017 no había podido pisar nadie después
de décadas del conflicto y ahora es una
de las Maravillas naturales del
departamento del meta
Por qué Porque Uribe meta es territorio
de paz vivimos tantos años el conflicto
que hoy Les vamos apostando al turismo
por ser liberal Entonces los dos lo
mataron
igual que el cañón del guape detrás de
mí esta la cascada del amor ambos
lugares están ubicados en el municipio
de la Uribe que durante décadas fue la
capital de las FARC Y que ahora gracias
a los procesos de paz han conseguido que
estos lugares se descubran y escondan el
ruido de las balas